hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
and you know I'm making this video
because today was uh Market was quite
active because um you know we got the
Jackson whole Symposium and uh the
Jerome Powell gave his strongest signal
yet that interest rate cuts are coming
uh soon you know there's a meeting
scheduled for uh September 17th through
the 18th and uh Powell literally said
the time has come for policy to adjust
and of course you know that's going to
add a lot of volatility into the market
and you know the market did not
disappoint if if you were to look at uh
you know the bar chart you know Market
immediately took off then came off went
down lower than where we were before
Paul started speaking went back up came
back off went back you know again lower
than where pow first started speaking
and now we're sort of back right around
where the market was when Powell started
speaking and when a market you know
picks up vola
because of something somebody said you
know obviously Powell's a very
influential person in the market um what
do I like to look for in the orderflow
is I just sort of go back to the basics
right I'll start to keep it simple I
will look at how the imbalances are
coming in because when you add all that
volatility into the
market you're going to get bars that are
stretched out like for example once uh
you know Paul started speaking here we
got this bar from 28 and a/4 all the way
up to uh
42 41 and 3/4 so about uh you know a 12o
move in 1 minute and then the subsequent
bars after that are about you know 8
nine 10 points not ticks points so these
are these are big moves these are $500
$400 $500 moves um in a minute and
that's why I say I start to focus in on
where the imbalances are coming in now
with imbalances in the order flow right
you know uh imbalance in the footprint
is in the two-way auction the volume on
the bid versus the volume on the offer
you know outweighs it by you know 4:1 or
whatever you want to set it at I like
4:1 some Traders use 3:1 others use a
higher percentage
and bars are going to have stacked
imbalances they're going to have
multiple imbalances where the imbalances
are spread out but first let's take a
look at stacked imbalances and and how I
like to um use them in my analysis so
for example here's a stacked buying in
Balance you got 36
1425 another buying stack buying a
balance here 38 2574 this is a stack
selling a balance 24 42 58 here's one uh
1291 okay
well I'm a big believer in putting
things in context okay when I have a
stacked imbalance coming in you know I I
want to sort of put it in context of
what is the market
doing all right so for example you know
obviously PA starts speaking I get a
nice stack buying and balance okay why
because obviously Paul's speaking and
and he's got he's talking about a policy
shift which is big news so okay that's
good I expect to see that right Market
goes
up then the market starts going sideways
I got a stack buying in Balance stack
selling in Balance right when a market
is going sideways I don't put as much
importance in stacked
imbalances okay as opposed to when a
market starts breaking out now here what
do we have we have Market is coming off
we put in a little bit of a swing low
right I mean the the low from you know
when po started speaking is is
here and this is 901 902 903 904 905 906
907 here and we get that pullback then
the market you know the market drops
from 41 and 3/4 all the way down to 35
and a half and then it starts rallying
okay so I know that I've got this
pullback right Market probed lower
didn't want to go any lower then I got
the aggressive buying coming in and the
market took off okay so I like to look
at stacked imbalances when we're sort of
breaking out like here this in this case
news broke
out and then here we get a pull back and
then we start going back up right now I
know that we got the aggressive buying
coming in and what's interesting about
where it pulled back to is where you had
that aggressive buying earlier that's
why I like to have zones drawn out so I
can see where that aggressive buying
started okay and I like to watch it as
the market comes back to it because when
a market comes back to some of these
zones right you always want to see you
know if there's any sign of more buying
if it's a stack buying balance if
there's any sign of support you know
because technically this is a market
generated support or resistance level
right right you can see here you got
Market selling off you got a lot
aggressive selling you got stack selling
and balance selling in Balance stack
selling and balance nextcell you got
five right here
okay even you know another one here and
you can see Market sort of came back
here just got around here it's rotated
around here for 3 minutes you got
another level here it's rotating around
but look at these two levels right here
around 40 and 42 Market came back up to
39 a
half sold all the way down to you know
26 again came back up sold off right
here you got a couple buying and balance
zones now this one is interesting
because you have a stack selling IM
balance area around the
5640 and then the aggressive buying
comes in at 5640 literally at the same
price level where you had the stack
selling a balance right that is not
something you see very often but if you
do see that that's actually a nice
bullish sign um in the short term it's
not again it's not something that I
would I would put my hat on for a trade
to last all day long but you know if
you're getting long off of this sort of
you know your previous think of it this
way your previous um resistance become
support you be looking to you know for
the market to keep going up I would not
be looking for this Market to sort of
rotate or stall out around this other um
stack cell of balance from earlier
around the 42 area and you know
basically the market goes up you know
puts in another 10 points from you know
the close of this bar up to
here and you know here's some more stack
sell balances okay we got one here we
got one here see the market got within
you know about a point of this stack
selling a balance and then started
coming off again again here it
came right up uh the stack selling
balance starts at 6 and a half we got up
to six the next bar get up to seven here
we get one tick through then the market
hasn't really come off it's just going
sideways right now okay we did have the
stack buying in balance and you can see
right in here it's come down got two
ticks through it here so theoretically
you know I'd be looking at we got you
know it's it's lunchtime now so Market
slowed down we do have support and
resistance here another resistance level
up there now again you know just sort of
talking about imbalances taking them in
context of the market
oftentimes you know a stacked imbalance
is caused
by just a big order coming through the
market okay and that that's that's how
it is sometimes right someone's got say
hey you know what I got 500 E minis to
buy or 500 to sell just get it done okay
and they'll just come in here sweep
through the market now again on a day
like today where you have that added uh
volatility from the FED
speaker you're seeing imbalances coming
on kind of volumes you know 22 17
1963 it's not heavy all right you see
here it's 24 42
58 that's why I say it's important to
put it in context because it's easy to
get excited oh I got a stack buying a
balance here I got to get long and what
happens Market sells off oh I got stack
selling in Balance what happens Market
starts to sell off then reverses starts
to get long try and put it in as much
context as you can here on this bar at
923 you know it's coming in about 5
minutes after the swing low is put in I
would prefer the stack buying about you
know sort of remove these two bars if
you could and and sort of slide this
over but fact is you have these two bars
coming in here um so it's about 5
minutes removed then you get another
stack buying and balance here people say
oh I got stack buying balance here and
the market didn't go higher well the
market just rallied from you know
basically 40 all the way up to 60 20
points and then you get another stack
buying
balance is this the Good context to take
it in I think it's much better to take
it at at a lower area put your swing
high in here you start coming off again
about 5 minutes later you got that
aggressive selling coming in again I I
would prefer to get the stack s a
balance a little bit closer to that
swing High okay here now again think of
the
context Market comes down the swing low
basically we're going you know sideways
in this tight I say tight range but it's
kind of in this range here let's call it
like this and we start breaking out
context this imbalance again I'm not
sure because we're sort of at the low
end of our range but here clearly all
right clearly we're breaking out and you
got that stack Sal a balance and then in
the next two
bars we dropped 20 points okay so that's
what I mean you know when I when I talk
about context again here you got a
couple stack buying IM balances in this
one bar but again it's coming in
about 4 minutes after that swing low has
been made
here okay think of
whoops itchy trigger itchy uh Mouse
finger um here got a nice swing High
defined swing high and in that swing
High you got the bar with the stack
selling a balance and the market starts
coming off nicely from there you know
from 48 down to 38 again in about 3
minutes all right
so you know the point is you know if if
you're looking at imbalances in the
market take them in context of where
they're coming in not just that they're
is an imbalance
because again you have instances where
it could just be a big order coming
through but if you have a stack buying
imbalance coming in at a swing low
what's that telling you is telling you
that the market sold off enough that
you've attracted buyers into the market
aggressive buyers into the market that
want to help take the market higher or
if you're at a swing High you know after
a 20 point rally and you see aggressive
selling coming
in that's probably something you can
take advantage of right because again
you want to align yourself with what the
big money is doing whether it's big
money through a big order um or maybe
people have information that you and I
just don't have all right so hopefully
uh you found this video helpful in
understanding on how to use stacked
imbalances in the market so thanks
everyone bye-bye